хочу передати Привіт мамочці Гліба яка
попросила щоб ми протрансували подію бо
вона не може бути сьогодні присутня
мамочка Гліба ми вас Всі обіймаємо
любимо І цьомаємо ті хто вчать і в мене
прохання написати чи вам Мене чути
чи вам все видно будь ласка Друзі бо я
на вас дуже сильно розраховую вот
Сьогодні ми зібралися щоби згадати про
нашого любого глібчика Сьогодні на жаль
руковини як Він загинув але але він вам
посміхається з портрету покажу вам що
тут зараз відбувається
повна зала людей
Всі зібралися щоби вшанувати Гліба
хтось сумує хтось сміється
Ірочка Можна я пройду я в прямому ефірі
от побратими з братів по зброї Хлопці ви
в прямому ефірі розкажіть чого ви
прийшли сюди поки Захід не стартував
першу чергу
День пам'яті
[музика]
потім згадати
наші часи
Ну і за загальну роботу
у вас нові шеврони тепер брати
по-зброєнь будуть імені Гліба Бабича і
це дуже круто
хлопці Бережіть себе Я вам зараз все
покажу поки ми не стартували ще дуже
багато людей
Гліб цього гідний щоб було дуже багато
людей
от Глібова банда - Це справа громадна
передай привіт Ти в прямому ефірі
розкажіть з якими думками ви сьогодні
прийшли
повний дисонанс тому що ну дуже важко
дуже Ну я стримую цілий день
і це дуже сумна подія про яку ми з
одного боку а з іншого боку побачити
скільки людей скільки справа громадських
друзів Гліба яких ми не бачили більше
аніж півтора року
з цього боку вони дуже радіють бачити
але друзі Давайте зробимо все можливе на
можливості щоб все ж таки перемогти цю
наволочки і зустрічатися вперше частіше
і друге по дуже позитивне
відпочинок в тому числі заради Гліба
Дякую Тоні Хто не знає Тоня голова
справи громад є друзі Я от всіх прошу
написати чи вам мене чути і видно тому
що я цього не знаю я вам щось говорю
говорю говорю але не знаю чи ви мене
чуєте і бачите і всіх до всіх величезне
прохання поширюйте цей стрім ставте свої
вподобайки пишіть свої коментарі щоб
якомога більше людей
побачила сьогодні це і згадала про Гліба
люди збираються потрошку
люди збираються і я вам скажу що не
дарма вибрали такий заклад це клуб
де давали свого часу Дякую пане любове
Дякую величезне
де давали свого часу концерти козаки для
козак сісти Гліб написав дуже багато
пісень ви сьогодні їх теж почуєте в
стрімі тому обов'язково приєднуйтеся
кажіть своїм друзям про це сьогодні буде
дуже багато всього цікавого і дуже
багато всього прогліба ви зможете його
згадати А може навіть і дізнатися щось
новеньке
[музика]
це покажу вам дарочка це
Глібова дочка
доця яку Гліб дуже любив Помахай ми в
прямому ефірі і сподіваюсь що Гліба мама
бачить
моя мама точно Дивиться
так що дівчата ми вам передаємо Привіт
Ми всі тут зібралися всі всі чекаємо на
старт заходу Це Сашко погребиське ліба
побратим Саша з якими думками ти прийшов
сьогодні на цей вечір Та напевно як і
більшість тих хто сьогодні сюди прийшов
а не вистачило
це єдина думка за цей рік напевно
коли ми говоримо про хліба найбільша
думка найбільш частіше Як вам було
тече Да нам всім не вистачає
[музика]
так ну друзі поки ми чекаємо
ви чекаєте разом з нами
це Віталій гайдукевич він сьогодні буде
ведучим цього нашого чудового Заходу Я
не буду до нього підходити бо він
готується щоб не збити його з думки він
сьогодні багато чого розкаже згадаємо
згадає про Гліба через вам покажу цю
фотку це одна з найулюбленіших моїх
фотографій бабіча бо він такий хитрий на
ній як оце такий був в житті на глебушка
друзі пишіть які от Які ваші улюблені
вірші Гліба Можливо ви їх читали
сьогодні Вони будуть тут теж звучати
А я зможу
рідним Гліба передати від вас привіт
це от Гліба видавець Іринка Іринка
хвилюєшся
великий острів
Я сьогодні їхала на цей захід і казала
ну хлібко давай допомагай
[сміх]
нічого не забула сказати це головне
зробило Все буде добре я в цьому
переконана Гліб з нами
Ну пішли друзі погуляємо З вами
подивимося що тут у нас є Хто тут в нас
є
багато військових бачите збираються
[музика]
це наша Мар'яша вона закинула роботу
помічником депутата і пішла
служити
Мар'янчик з якими думками сьогодні ти
прийшла сюди
з теплими
Я на жаль не змогла бути присутності
[музика]
вдалась якщо вона так сказати
зараз я не могла це пропустити по я весь
цей рік не могла сприйняти цю втрати
взагалі тобто я
думала що там Закінчиться війна чи
будуть там якісь моменти відпочинку і ми
зустрінемося то я не сприймалася
закінчиться тоді всі обнімуться всі
зустрінуться але цього не станеться їй
це зараз тільки сприймається
[музика]
оце була світла обійму тебе від себе від
всіх наших глядачів
передаю Мар'яні вашого обіймашку друзі
пішли далі погуляємо
Пішли погуляємо поки Люди готуються так
от бачите люди вже трошки попівасіку так
як хліб любив
гриб бабіч любив віскарюк
і
Якщо я не помиляюся Ром
були одними з його улюблених алкогольних
напоїв
Ну сьогодні тут не забороняється нікому
брати Це теж справа громад привітайтеся
друзі Ви в прямому ефірі
всі прийшли тихенько на гальорці
Софія Федина ми зараз її теж спитаємо
сь
таким одним єдиним великим цілим І це
просто
Софієчка ти в прямому ефірі Передавай
привіт людям Розкажи з якими думками ти
сьогодні сюди прийшла сьогодні цілий
ранок співаю Богдан зброю мені брати Не
сумуй мила не сумуй мати хлопці дельове
ще йдуть з ворога плату прати
журналісти питалися Які відчуття мене
сьогодні А знаєш з одного боку хочеться
і плакати і сумно і болять
це зрозуміло але з якщо поки я постійно
всім повторюю що цей біль ми маємо
трансформувати в злість і силу залізти
все робити ворога напевно не Гліб у
цього хотів найбільше щоб Москалів на
нашій землі не було і щоб якомога менше
втратив нас було Мирного жанру дякую
софчик
Вибач
довели довели Софію до сліз хлопці
побратими всі приходять всі збираються
люди багато людей в формі друзі пишіть
пишіть свої думки поширюйте це відео
зараз стартуне вже офіційний захід щоби
Якомога більше людей могла побачити і
згадати про глібожку
десь тут зафіксуюся
будемо чекати разом з вами Поки ви
збираєтеся
Я чекаю на ваші коментарі сьогодні буде
багато спогадів Я думаю і
в людей буде можливість просто вийти на
сцену в режимі вільного мікрофону
висловитися і в принципі якщо ви теж
хочете щось сказати зі сцени можете
написати це в коментарях ми спробуємо це
озвучити
в кінці в кінці під кінець нашого стріму
почуєте почуєте себе дуже багато людей
це дуже класна зала повна в принципі так
і має бути Да так і має бути до митця
яким був і є Гліб
має збиратися завжди повна зала це дуже
круто Я дуже пишаюся тобою
Тамара горіха зерня прийшла
авторка бестселера доця Вони теж дружили
з глібом дуже так що сьогодні дуже
багато тут класних цікавих людей
[музика]
дуже багато
так так хліб - це Україна Я погоджуюся
гриб дуже крутий Дякую панелі любович
вітання Я зачитаю тим хто не бачить
повідомлення щирі вітання рідним друзям
Люба бабіча та усім хто пам'ятає
Великого українця сумує разом з вами
Дякуємо дорога Софія за ваш патріотизм а
також всі ЄС Харків Привіт Харків Дякую
що ви тримаєтеся болить фізично бо дуже
важка втрата дуже світла людина так дуже
болить але але гриб прожив дуже класне
життя чесно Він завжди живий оспівував
Якби ще чекаємо підходять побратими
хвилинки 3-4 як можна каву Тільки якщо
перекур будь ласка виходьте надо далеко
потім швидко
до 5 хвилин
так ну ви чули все
ви чули друзі
5 хвилин ви теж можете перекурити але не
вимикайте трансляцію
бачите хлопці вітаються всі по формі це
це все побратими Гліба це всі хто
побритах по зброї його знали
Та й взагалі по життю хліб дуже класна
людина В нього завжди дуже багато друзів
було
і хоча він непростий мав характер але
його любили всі беззаперечно
хлібчика завжди було дуже багато друзів
бо він достойна гідна і класна людина
так
сьогодні ще буде сюрприз для вас друзі
яку підготував Фома
гурт Мандри буде презентація нової пісні
пісні присвяти по суті своїй
на перемогу
да до речі що я вам хочу сказати якщо ви
хочете
зробити якісь внесок допомогти родині
Гліба наприклад То ви можете зайти на
сторінку справи громад і фізично
задонатити або на пам'ятник глібобабічу
бо зараз будуть його скоро вже
встановлювати на алеї героїв на який він
похований або на перевидання його книжки
я сподіваюся в більшості з вас книжка
Гліба Бабича є з віршами сьогодні до
речі в когось вона була якщо я її побачу
то я вам її покажу як вона виглядає
А якщо її нема у вас то ви зможете
отримати цю книжку вже тільки після
перевидання Тому що весь наклад
розкупили Я говорила з видавцем і Ірина
сказала що все книжка закінчилася там ще
якісь
рештки були
книжковому арсеналі але я так розумію що
вони дійсно вже всі розпродані тому
друзі да Якщо ви хочете включитися то ви
можете фізично підключитися до справи
перевидання глібової книжки або
задонатити на його пам'ятник я в опис до
цієї трансляції потім скину посилання на
банку
і закріплюю її першим посиланням ви
зможете ви зможете побачити перечитати
передивитися і зробити це скоро стартує
вже наш захід
бачите люди спілкуються люди раді бачити
одні одних це дуже круто Насправді це
дуже круто
Гліб насправді завжди був душею компанії
і Ну от реально можу вам сказати що він
знову нас всіх зібрав і всі вдячні йому
так ще прочитаю вам коментар Моя мама
дуже любила Гліба слідкувала за його
військовими творчим шляхом На жаль мама
пішла незадовго за хлібом вічна і світла
пам'ять всім патріотам України Так я
приєднуюся до цього я приєднуюся до
цього ми сьогодні були у Гліба в гостях
на цвинтарі На цій на майбутнє але
героїв чесно вам скажу
вона розростається друзі вона
розростається І це дуже важко
вона розростається і величезна кількість
прапорів
українських а це означає що гинуть наші
хлопці гинуть
тому ми завжди маємо пам'ятати яка ціна
того що ми от можемо навіть сьогодні
зібратися згадати Гліба посміятися
поплакати разом
ми завжди це маємо пам'ятати
дуже багато дуже багато людей ще
продовжують збиратися
насправді
на Цей заклад захід відкривали
реєстрацію тому що
ну довелося обмежувати кількість людей
тому що дуже багато людей хотіли прийти
а зала просто всіх не помістила я часто
вас слухаю і завжди думаю кого і за ким
ідуть люди з першої сторінки ви
справжньої Україна професійно приємний
голос ви живете цим Дякую вам величезне
Я думаю що
не тільки мій голос виступає за Україну
зараз але Ми всі маємо триматися разом
це правда і дякую вам за підтримку і
Дякую що ви зараз на цьому стрімі
дивитися поширюєте це важливо Це важливо
для всіх друзів Гліба я вам чесно скажу
для родини для нас для всіх це важливо
можливо щоб ви писали як ви його теж
любите нам всім приємно це почитати ну
мені точно чесно кажу навіть до себе
хлібабіч був великою людиною творцем
дуже відважними талановитим Борис
Сергеевич це правда
Гліб дуже сміливий Гліб дуже крутий Гліб
ніколи нічого не боявся він лазив
Вибачте в таких сраках фронту що не
кожному дано він мав кілька днів
народжень тому що
ще за часів коли війна називалася атою
оос
глібчик служив Гліб втілив життя такі
проекти неймовірні
що люди досі згадують про них і досі
просять якось їх відтворити наприклад
система відеоспостереження яку
встановлювали ще до повномасштабного
Вторгнення в різних бригадах на фронті
Вона досі працює і вона вже врятувала
життя сотні бійців Я вам не дарма
показую поки це все говорю усміхнене
обличчя хліба бо він ну він просто
фізично горів своїми проектами і отака
хитра мордаха була завжди коли він щось
вигадував і там навіть було таке що він
там міг вигадати якісь для цієї камери
спостереження маленький двірничок який
під час дощу цю камеру очищував
автоматично ну тобто хліб звичайно Гліб
просто просто унікальна людина От і все
я дякую всім хто зараз нас дивиться
Дякую всім хто пише свої коментарі
Повірте це важливо для нас для всіх ми
це потім все перечитуємо і
радіємо нам всім приємно особливо родині
друзям Гліба Бабича
Я сьогодні буду з вами в стрім і пару
годин тому ви не переключаєтеся
обов'язково мусите все подивитися
сьогодні буде фільм про Гліба Бабича
сьогодні будуть різні відео яких ви
можливо не бачили навіть якщо слідкували
за ним сьогодні будуть дуже класні
спогади від близьких йому людей а
Повірте про баббіча є ще згадати є ще
згадати
бо він класнючий він класнючий
і поки з вами тут я прогуляюся дякую
всім хто ставить лайки Дякую не тому що
мені дуже потрібні лайки а тому що це
впливає на поширення відео Друзі ваші
коментарі ваші лайки впливають на
поширення відео тому я весь час вам про
це нагадую І поясню чому Тому що
хорошого контенту правильного контенту і
правильних людей в ефірі чи то в Ютубі
чи то на телебаченні має бути більше це
моя глибоке переконання тому друзі не
забувайте не забувайте про реакції тому
що Youtube і так дуже обмежує все що
пов'язано з Україною і з війною На жаль
але ми маємо ми маємо бути на
інформаційному фронті першими
так
Так
я думаю що скоро вже будемо стартувати
бачите ну зала просто повна просто повна
можна піти спробувати знайти
порожнє крісло ще трошки є ще трошки є
але я думаю вони доберуться ще до нас
дуже багато людей
і це супер класно
пішли перейдемося Подивимося може ще
хтось прийшов цікавий
подавайка та коментар метод просування
контенту в Ютубі Так я вам про це і кажу
це абсолютно точно тому я і кажу вам що
ви ставили свої вподобайки і коментували
тому що це безпосередньо впливає на те
щоб поширювати
контент А це важливо для всіх можливо
щоби люди дивилися не
якесь лайно Вибачте а дивилися
про справжніх
Для мене це важливо сподіваюсь що для
вас також
[музика]
цікаво що тут точно зібралися всі свої
всі патріотичні
[музика]
треба вже друзі нам напевно підганяти
того гайдукевич
бо я вже починаю втомлюватися в мене вже
починають втомлюватися язик Хоча я не
втомлююся про Гліба розказувати ніколи
але вже хочеться щоб ви ще подивилися на
інших людей послухали не тільки мене але
скоро вже будемо починати
прийшов порох
Марина Анатоліївна
про це класно
Петро Олексійович сьогодні до речі був
на цвинтарі у хліба
;
вона спитати
таким щастям і весь на дні коли літака
[оплески]
[музика]
та життя моє
Чорненький
[музика]
вітання всім хто тут
Дякую що ви є
знаєте Ми цілий сценарій написали як
воно має бути І зараз я розумію що ми
робили це дарма воно буде як завгодно
тільки не так як ми плануємо
Іра ми з'їли Білоцерківської мали
партнерами тут бути говорити якісь
правильні речі давати вам слово і зараз
ми розуміємо що ви все одно скажете так
як воно лежить на душі у вас у кожного І
щоб по фіналу Ми отримаємо на порядок
кращий вечір ніж те як ми могли сиділити
ви знаєте рік тому коли нас зібрався
ліфт
Там біля Михайлівського хтось сказав
та було світло Слухай ми надто мало
зустрічаємося разом тут так просто в
житті не по справах і тому ми надто
багато і часто зустрічаємося тоді коли
хтось іде
треба якось це виправляти але
якби Гліб був тут він би обійняв кожного
сказав як добратка це скажи фірмована
і Якби він був тут і побачив у когось
сльози він сказав Ну команда
тому Давайте без минулого часу без Якби
він з нами він все бачить він бере
участь він відповідає на ваші фрази і
кожному
вашій голові так і тими словами які
знаєте тільки ви і було б справедливо Ну
до речі зауважте ми тут в місті де живе
рок-н-рол А це те що було в душі і було
б справедливо щоб цей вечір
ввечер разом з глібом був розпочатий
поезіями і гітарою ну це поет
музикант і воїн Фома разом з нами і Ну
по-перше Тому треба
відпустити щоб він встиг на свої справи
але ми подумали що
в них є спільність спогади по подіях які
були в ппд 206-го і я думаю що сама може
і гітарою голосом і віршами
[оплески]
Всім доброго дня
реально з глібом я познайомився саме на
лаврській саме 26 лютого рік тому
і я знав чув про нього але я не Був
знайомий особисто і весь цей час коли ми
перетиналися він був надзвичайний Гліб
був надзвичайно інтелегентний
надзвичайно мудрий надзвичайно Я знаю
[музика]
Велика радість завжди коли зустрічаєш
таких людей і коли я вже відкрив ще
ширше і його творчість
Я не був так щільно знайомий Я взагалі
був вражений цим масштабом цим рівним
тому звичайно Для нас це велика для всіх
ну це не це ми знаємо що він зараз тут
має присутніх бо живе кожного з нас в
серці і
це для нього я не до того таку
коротеньку програму я прочитаю вірш один
з улюблених віршів Гільберг який мені
подобається
і
заспівають одну пісню
вірш
коли смерть присяде на брудство спитає
Ну що тут Ти коли нас як тісто місить
вогняний вал Я не стану Суми так і Бога
вийду в канал арти у піхоти з ортоєм і
богом завжди прямий канал
заглушаючи криком в рацію хребки голос
війни
продиктуюча рівні цифри наче магічний
код
скрипне радіо прийняв тримайтесь пацани
а решту слів не почую бо знову накрив
приходу
оживина позиції з стадо з сталевих
слонів поверне своїх хоботів в сторону
наших бід і зайди в стволи склацанням
стиснути Божий Гнів для швидкої доставки
без декларації і ми навіть янголи
завмерли в небі як театральний зал небо
теж полюбляє сипати снігом
дощем дочекалися наче кулак по всесвіту
стукнув залп другий третій а потім іще
іще а над нами небо улуснуло наче
віконне скло аж земля підстрибнула і
трохи змінився ландшафт смерть сиділа на
бруствері більше немає змало та зі
стиснутих рук повернулися в серце душа
що там поради Прийом Та все по плюсах
Братан так вломили що вщент і ціле
більше нема
що я ще відповім вклоняюсь тобі артар
недаремно вас кличуть богам Ой не дарма
і А зараз я більше хотів представити хто
не знайомий ще одна людина з якої я
познайомився в 206 батальйоні
Анатолій дибить старший солдат дешеве
марусиних ведмедів які нещодавно тільки
демобілізувався по віку
[оплески]
і ми з ним
творчо зараз багато спілкуємося
відзняли нещодавно кліп з головні ролі з
Анатолієм по пісні про солдата що
вертаються з війни і зараз буде
представлено взагалі нова пісня Це можна
сказати прем'єра і ми разом з граємо
присвячуємо глібом як і всім українським
Героям які
[музика]
зараз на небесах і в серці кожного з нас
все пісня Подяка і пісня про свято
[музика]
[оплески]
жили у нас горища
[музика]
неправильно до краю Перлина чи там
гриніли гармати на рідні міста і
засипали їх хати єднаємось брати і
сестри Водолій всі ті хто вкатіні і на
полі бою всі ті хто у небі про вас ще
згадають монетні твори вже карбують
мигдаль вона і творить вже гарбують
[музика]
медалікому Полі всі Маки червоні кричать
прапо
рищем і думала нам
на сміх
є напалом устрої групи сухої землі у
долоні ти їде приходить до тата чи мама
батьки до коханої батьки до дітей
[музика]
[оплески]
ніхто як далі Все буде
[музика]
і багато
із вже не тут і не
знав то що ж має статися слідом байду
щоб кожен не
ті люди
кожен із нас два вони лише про себе
поважав знову тебе і падає
в мене вже знову
так і па
дає
така сцену тримаєш солдати у шанцях
умертю
або Перемоги
[музика]
[оплески]
щоб на
У Божому ранку про Васю країну завжди
поміряла
[оплески]
цю країну
[музика]
[оплески]
Палац Україна
[музика]
[оплески]
!
[музика]
[оплески]
твій вихід
[музика]
Добрий день Ми прекрасні Раптом ми не
знайомі Мене звуть Ірина Білоцерковська
Я та сама щаслива видавчиня який вдалося
змусити глівку видати його першу і на
жаль єдину книгу яка називається вірші
та пісні і завдяки цій книзі взагалі
дуже багато
історій трапилося і
спогади про ці історії наповнюють мене
От прям зараз і я їхала сюди Я дуже
хвилювалася Чесно кажучи для мене це
величезна відповідальність з Віталієм
разом і перед також оновленою публікою
але я згадувала як ми їздили з глібом
У нього такий величезний досвід виступу
виступів різних концертів і ви знаєте
Він завжди хвилювався він настільки
хвилювався що інколи не міг дібратися і
ми десь там збоку з ним спілкувалися про
якусь фігню І тоді
він набирався ругався зі мною і йшов на
сцену
і я їхала сьогодні будемо і казали
Глібка Ну давай допомагай мені давай щоб
я не позорилася
і ми Прописали цей сценарій дійсно для
того щоб я могла тримати себе в руках Бо
для мене ця історія дуже чемна історія
правління - це дуже особиста моя
дуже особисті мої спогадами
і щоб я не збилася то я просто хочу
розказати про що ми сьогодні з вами
блокуємо говорити Тут ми будемо слухати
спогади різних людей який про нього
будемо чути його вірші
знов його пісні Ми будемо розповідати і
розмовляти знову про його книгу і про
неймовірний конкурс імені глібабадича
який організували видавництво білка - це
дещо дивовижно Ви самі це усвідомити і
якщо ви схочете сказати кілька слів то
обов'язково у нас буде відкритий
мікрофон
але звичайно почати
хочеться з слів самого хліба з його
образом з його текстів
таким яким його побачила камера
[музика]
це що ж таке
солі тут технічні якісь неполадки
що це в нас
щось в нас тут не туди
[музика]
ротация
грибавич 5 років війни 6 ротацій пройшов
Мар'їнку широке не Водяне авдіївку
Дебальцеве керував згодом вогневою
підтримки десятої гірсько-штурмової
бригади за селу А ще поет блогер і вже
як півтора роки політик
[музика]
прийшов зі зброєю як зовні спини сказали
Стрибай дай на стільці дільник треба
дорогу відкидає оцінка твоя буде з
намилася тільки щоб
[музика]
позивний
прийшов зі мною
у меня был когда-то творческий псевдоним
доктор лентяев вот доктора
ти кажеш що бачив світ а я бачив пір за
тебе те що весь бруд весь під це тільки
стежка по небу все буде чи тут Чи десь
бо доля по нас проката
вміщається весь на дні рюкзака солдата
[музика]
[сміх]
[оплески]
[музика]
мені треба щоб тебе не
було
очі
сонечко
[музика]
тільки не знаю кому
але дитину
все марно
і не встигнув А ти мовчки під
вівся своє речі і піднявся в дитину наче
яблуком на плечі Ми пішли поки небо
вздовж рік та вокзалів я казала не треба
мене далі І була я маленька і була Як
дитиною
тоненьке до моєї країни і казала не можу
все скінчилося все марно
хмари
[музика]
без культури нації нема якби змовимо на
цій немає
це нас важливі речі і пока поки поки
вони існують і ми будемо існувати
добре заговорюють будь-які
на наші з тобою
це життя вимого віджиму розумієте все
життя коли тебе стискує воно з такою
вижимається сік саме в творчості саме в
віршах в емоціях простіше це передати
решті людей я цитую картинки вижу ещё у
вас є правда чаще дорогу зеленку і
терикон ну достаточно Мига что было стал
во мне пробуждается чёткого сна боевой
Дракон у нас учили когда-то верить
прощать любить молзащиту невинным
голодного Накорми но в процессе защиты
многие Пришлось убить И теперь нам не
просто по прием быть людьми щоб ти
наробив нове створюючи якусь гілку
нового світу і яке б діло ти наробив
якщо тобі цікаво якщо подобається
розумієш навіть на війні я не можу А ти
якісь свій світ Історії і він живе вже
завдяки
може жити вже без тебе І це неймовірна
річ
[музика]
послугу
вона була
залишилося щось скачати
[музика]
допоможуть моє
[оплески]
серце
на фронті тільки Бабич міг
[музика]
знайти
дуже люблю займатися всім до чого
докинусь і чим я можу займатися не тут
те що я там я спився за це за це потім
за це цікаво А коли ти несеш як жонглер
декілька предметів і
тримаєш щоб упорити це здорово то це був
займатися бізнесом в мене була музична
студія справжня
знову займатися творчествами бізнесами
міг різним займатися так цікаво жити
розумієш
Коли ти в тебе декілька грамів і ти
можеш
[музика]
балансуватись в тебе є
з цього на що перемотатися
зараз мені доводиться зиматися і
політикою ти знаєш і багатьма е-е
багатьма речами і тому мовою фронту і це
але це реально Це я от я такий тренер
все що потрібно для добудування системи
на нових дуже чудових позиціях бачити
батальйонний комплект для 10-ї бригади
за спиною у велику бачать
і як теж об'їдають побратимів
замість двох ящиков
споживає сама бачите маску блоки - це
веселий скандинавський Бог хитрощів
такогоства Що я можу сказати Ворог у
нашому готуйтесь
рятуйтесь від цього не побачите ви цього
не будете контролювати але ви все це
відчуєте особу
це створена кро
ком поширю завезли кістки
Аврора за тихо заходив у двір і землю
Лав на шматки
[музика]
бо поруч нікого щоб став і закрив від
лиха І ворогів бо ми полягли
А тих хто вцілів
до контакта
совсем немного
[музика]
полю бою
сльозами Я сі
ллю
А на полі витікої
[музика]
обрав Мольфар в долоні землю
шепотів землі я мушу
будували тут
свою душу
[музика]
не-не-несено моя
сила додаємо
[музика]
[оплески]
світ земля в долонях
[музика]
весілля
твоє кожному
на колі
нах
[музика]
[оплески]
Отже наше відео ми бачим гуляє туман
[музика]
що
я бачу кошмар які насняться
частиною партією
може те як воює на тій стороні і бачу
собі в плівці
ці відбувається
[музика]
ікона народна України а мені зрозуміло
все в моєму стилі Він вбиває страх як
заразом пеніцилін саундтрек у нього всі
знайомі пісні А під ранок останній
[музика]
ти знаєш буває Я хочу назад
по одному принаймні
новий що я бачу кошмарах які не сняться
мені чи копають
чи може курив траву чи кричу я успіх
все чому не бояться
допомога
відспівав
[музика]
пекельний плюс
ваша черного
[оплески]
друзей
дяка бо я знав близько на этой войне
за что-то не просто так не за деньги не
за власть
[музика]
все життя за ці роки склалося і я не
просто повірив Я знаю що правильно
розумієш кінець війни - це тоді коли моя
країна буде абсолютно вільна своїм до
квадратного сантиметра окрім пам'яті
то все це
є
35 завершеної справи
бо я думаю що ми
завершення в Україні не закінчиться
ніколи
[музика]
незалежно від щирості болю не хвилюйся
серденько щоб не сталось знаєш завжди
над тобою твої діти отримають неба Я
Світанок по полі зустріну і побачив
Бог до сонця за руку веде Україну
камуфляж щасливою бабусею
А чим закінчилося
Я бажаю тобі
того щоб скоро будуть такі часи коли все
це розсиплеться як прах ми знову тут
будемо
спілкуватися
і Це буде просто Куб і буде знову буде
або ми всі здохнули
[оплески]
[музика]
в цьому душі
занадто багато слів
як Тримай Не питай не плач
Ангел в печі
Бобрик чужих коліс
і про
[музика]
пав
досить сумних пісень
[музика]
сумних пісень
невпевнено
але тут
Я знаю книга буде практично Як казав
Чужий класик і напевно що варто
зауважити що це буде абсолютно інша
книга ніж так трава У вас є знаєте чому
була у хліба Мрія і він абсолютно чітко
до неї шов він хотів А ви чули на
початках війни
Гліб і співав і дуже багато в нього було
цього
він мислив російськими римами він мислив
російськими реченнями і він вмів дуже
оригінальний їх загортати але при цьому
він хотів перекласти весь свій період
російської поезії українською мовою
це буде і над цим працює зараз
видавництво Білка і там в цій книзі
будуть ще спогади це надзвичайно важливо
Бо це буде враження тих хто знав хліба
близько і по-різному в різних обставинах
але от про це напевно що краще скаже
Тамара таріха зернято
Іра потім хто ти маєш додати свою
історію
дякую
і я не знаю як не плакать я наприклад
Готуюся зараз вибухнуть фонтаном таким і
з усіх
пішла на цю подію А мені консьєржка в
спину кричить Тамара На гулянку йдеш Я в
сукні А я біжу отак от спідницю в цьому
кажу На гулянку На гулянку такі в нас
гулянки зараз цього разу
Ми
з Вірою
з Дариною Звичайно що знали що про Гліба
треба писати
незалежно від того Тобто це прикро
обставина те що він загинув але для нас
це не те що зупиняє нас в нашій роботі в
глібовій роботі і це відчуття що його
смерть не зупинила а ніби просто треба
її враховувати в дужках але продовжувати
робити свою справу це так би глід Мені
здається робив і робить і коли ми думали
про цю книгу спочатку йшлося про серію
інтерв'ю які повинна була взяти
професійний журналісти там пішла робота
яка стрибала потім вона застопорилося
якось потім ми з Вірою придумали таку
ідею зібрати спогади ще свого боку
поговорити з друзями з родиною І от
Перший день коли
з Дариною зустрілися в ресторани Ні ми
сиділи в трьох і йшлося про те щоб дочка
першої розповіла спогади про свого тата
про свого батька якісь історії якісь
інтерв'ю у нас було це дуже болісно ми
метео плакали посміялися то одна одну
підбадьорювали хтось одна замовкає дві
других говорять І от на найбільшому
такому надриві коли ми вже були Ну серце
зупиняється
відкриваються двері ми сиділи в окремому
цьому кабінеті заходи офіціант і
заносить нам голий манекен чоловічий і
ставить біля нас
наше німе запитання Що це таке він каже
спецзамовник
Ну я думаю ми перший раз цю Ми в
ресторані він тільки відкрили або Мало
що може
лишаєте він пішов ми повернулись
і каже нам приплутав замовник
і ми сприйняли це як привіт від Гліба
це цей курйоз такий він ніби задав
тональність того і тоді я кажу Іра давай
не будемо писати інтерв'ю давайте
запишемо історію зберемо в кого зможемо
розпитаємо і запишемо історію про хліб і
ми так і зробили
поділивши цю роботу основні інтерв'ю
проводили Ірина тому що знову ж таки
вона сильніша твердіша і відповідальніше
за мене кріпша а я в основному плакала
але це не заважало Тобто ти очима то
плачеш а руки-то працюють і
розшифровувала я обробляла Звісно це не
вийшли суто історії чи якісь покрих
величе якісь там легенди в цих спогадах
дуже сильно відчуваються і я зберігала
тональність голос
мова тих людей які ділилися своїми
спогадами про Гліба тому що я впевнена
хоча ми зараз переробляємо зараз ми в
чергове переробляємо це замочилище
редакторів ще там людей які це все
літературно знову переписують безкінечно
Ну ця робота все одно буде завершена так
чи інакше до нашого задоволення але для
мене особисто стало не те що Відкриття А
я отримала підтвердження що
глід по-перше лишився не тільки в
пам'яті лід лишився у вчинках глів
лишився камертоном моральним і
вказівником і точкою відліку з якою
величезна кількість людей звіряють свої
вчинки і свої думки і ці люди є
надзвичайно достойними
людьми відданими Україні і нашій
перемозі і Гліб він просто
він йшов небезпечною дорогою з його
досвідом з його вміннями з його знаннями
з його інтуїцією Він повинен був по цій
дорозі пройти безпечно і дійти до кінця
нічого він не повинен був поступитися
але маленька секундна обставина він
просто краєм краєм одягу в самому кінці
зачепив
оцю порожнечу оцю тінь яка супроводжує
багатьох
насадки і вона його вислухала до себе
але я так думаю що хліб він не здався
навіть з того боку
Я так думаю що він
домовився поборовся розпихав усіх
нігтями ногами пояснив кому не пояснив
без пояснень сказав що я маю лишитися
тут Ваші
[музика]
другі треті світи почекають Я повинен
бути отут дуже близько цих людей на цій
стежці і він так лишився Ну от я так
думаю і я це відчуваю дуже багато людей
я перепрошую я думаю що Ну що ви мене
хочете я все одно ти то пишуться
він лишається з нами підтримує прикриває
дає сили де є сміх де є впевненість і
дає віру в те що ми просто взялися
і ще одним братом і ще одним
ангелом-охоронцем і ще однією людиною
яка нас просто прикриває з того боку
Ну так склалося війна
[музика]
вчора мені малий мій стрічка син каже
так давно тато не дзвонив не писав 6
років каже ти знаєш Мам Ти впевнена що
він не загинув а ти від мене не
приховуєш
війна війна впливає на дітей він вона
впливає на нас війна впливає на наших
чоловіків не всі а
ми не вибирали цього але я дуже пишаюся
тим як ми всі тримаємось
Я дуже пишаюся тим як ми цю війну на
собі несем як ми йдемо цією стежкою
втрачаючи друзів втрачаючи рідних але
все одно Ми якось збираємося до купи і
пишемо те що вважали за потрібне
говоримо робимо
воюємо далі І я вірю що кожен наш кожен
наш
вчинок нас все одно наближає до перемоги
ну то це таке і
я сподіваюсь що книга наша вийде
Обов'язково
я сподіваюся що ви її всі прочитаєте і
зрозумієте те що я так сумбурно
намагаюся зараз сказати і побачити яке
по відношенню до Гліба яке велике тепле
коло сильне людей які жили разом з ним
дружини разом з ним І продовжують жити
дружити разом з ними
Дякую вам величезним взагалі про книгу
хочу сказати трохи бо це буде щось
неймовірне ми коли збирали ці спогади ці
історії про Гліба нам здалося що ми
проживаємо разом з ним його величезне
життя він там на відео казав що він
трьохгранний і Да він мільйон огранный
чесно Це абсолютно неймовірна людина і
ви всі
дізнаєтесь коли придбаєте книгу
наскільки це була фантастична це є
фантастична людина фантастичний Ангел в
нас окремо його така я не знаю місця
суперсила це вміти збирати навколо себе
людей і от в цій книзі Він наче
продовжує це неначе продовжує збирати
навколо себе коло людей які зараз
допомагають нам видати цю книгу
у нас був такий випадок ми приймали
участь в новому літературному конкурсі в
Краматорську його колись принесли коли
вже був окупований Донецьк і він
називався Кальміус і Це був новий
конкурс Я запросила тут Гліба він
приїхав але людей було зовсім мало І я
сказала глід ти знаєш Мені так незручно
але тут може бути буквально 2-3 чоловік
людини я сіяч і ще хтось він сказав
фіртне знаєш це таке місто
Краматорськ А в якому я буду виступати
навіть якщо тут буде 2 3 2 3 людини
і коли ми зайшли в зал він був повний в
цьому місці ніхто його не знав і це така
магія яка залишилась з нами після того
як хліб пішов І зараз я хочу запросити
на цю сцену Петра Порошенка
[оплески]
[сміх]
Дякую Ірино Дякую Тамара
Дякую тобі
Лентяй
Дякую за те що ти нас всіх зібрав
у кожного є дуже важливі справи І вони
були Протягом цього року
але сьогодні
Гліб нас запросили ми тут
хліб як багатогранна особистість Бо для
мене він був
шестере танців
десятка
Він дуже скромно людина коли йому треба
було він проривався до мене і казав про
те що комплекс відеоспостереження для
бригади недостатньо
тому має бути в кожному батальйоні потім
кожній роті а потім у всіх бригадах
збройних сил Це буде робити він але
здається
[сміх]
і все в нього вдавалося би він
на перший погляд дуже скромна людина
запалював своєю енергетикою
своєю вірою в успіх
і це було по всьому від бригадного
комплексу
до ящичка з полуницями За який нас дуже
критикували на російському телебаченні
що ми з ним об'їдали українських солдат
спочатку полуниця Маліна абрикоси
але завжди був цей компонент
воїн
не тільки водив за собою взводу і
підтримки а вів і мобілізовував парад
тоді коли поради були забороні
він був на чолі він не давав зганьбити
праву патріотів і справу воїнів
І це дуже добре знають
Трійця потужна Трійця братів по зброї
лентяй патріот і підлий
До речі вітання від підлоги він
душа його з нами але він зараз
невиконання
Боярки на острові
і робить так Так потрібно хлібу і нам
всім справи
Ми не маємо Тамара права плакати зараз
він нас запросив подивитися
[музика]
і ті кадри з того тої нашої зустрічі
Даринка в будинку офіцерів це було щось
неймовірне він
перший раз в житті він сварився на мене
щасливий був здивований і був дуже
щасливий коли
зал вибухнув оплесками
хліб митець
це митець нашого кола цих сотень людей
які сьогодні зібралися тут
він є
лідери представник української культури
на відміну від тих
Міністрів дискультурія
і
командувать серіалів про свиней і хряків
які чомусь мають так показувати Україну
от Подивіться на хліба оце є наша
Україна навіть якщо він пише російською
мовою бо там душа українська
я хочу сказати Ірині тамарі книга буде
Ми з Мариною до цього долучаємось
повністю профінансуємо нові всі факти
і всіх вас потрібно
і Тамара Вони все зроблять Я знаю з цієї
енергетикою Я їм вірю і не лише книга от
Сьогодні ми з вами посиділи подивилися
буде фільм
бо енергетиках Гліба з екрану вона дуже
порівнюється з тим що ти читаєш його з
таких хоча
його проза і про смерть
на просторі напроти
і про
арту
яка завжди допоможе
виявилося не завжди
і про
світ
наш звар
який
вміщується на дні рюкзака солдата і те
що Гліб сказав я записав собі точно
цитувати зараз фільми
його прогноз
А він там близько до Бога Він знає що це
буде
все
розсиплеться як прах
буде мир
з нашої перемоги А вони
всі здохнуть
[оплески]
це я виконую обіцянки що починається Все
не заповнює
плані була не записана але я хочу просто
до слів і Петра Олексійовича і всіх хто
перед цим говорив до спогад додати
сучасні відчуття
відчуття коли мені
зателефонувала Наталка
і каже У нас буде
вечір спогадів про Гліба
її запросила мене сюди
А в мене просто шок
думаю невжеж тільки рік пройшов таке
відчуття що ціле життя ціле життя ми вже
прожили без нього
І все Це життя не вчились жити без нього
Але у нас нічого не виходить
весь час багато питань які поставали що
треба вирішити на когось вийти щось
Закрити якісь
проблеми виникали
і
на питання А хто має це питання
вирішувати хто був закріплений А це
питання які він вирішував це проекти які
він супроводжував це
і це безліч таких питань а що робити
далі І таке Було відчуття весь час
складалося що
всі хто залишився в команді Гліба Бабича
тут зараз вони тимчасово виконують його
обов'язок
чекаючи коли він повернеться і знову
візьметься за свої справи
і
Це дійсно відчуття його присутності
воно по-перше накладає дуже велику
відповідальність за те що не можна
зробити погано не можна зробити або як
не можна відкласти А треба робити тому
що якщо б він був він би зробив і зробив
на відмінно це правда
а по-друге
Це надає сил
і честь Що робиш продовжуєш справи хліба
Бабича
тому
Дякую що ти з нами
Дякую що надихаєш і даєш сили рухатись
вперед і робити багато-багато
Дякую Марина і я купив би щоб ми
сьогодні згадали бо
з братів по зброї
з республіки справи громадської
солідарності з наших фракцій більше двох
з половиною тисяч
У нас є найбільше представництво
ще пішли служити
жодна громадська організація не
мобілізувало таку кількість людей а якщо
ми до цього долучимо ваших хлопців
ваших чоловіків
це буде
велике велике кількість зберігання і на
жаль 54 з них
пішли на небо
це хліб це Олег Барна якому дуже любимо
це Тарас жеребецький Софійка це Юра
Каракай
нарешті отримав від влади
давно заслужений орден
і ми кожного з них будемо пам'ятати
Брати по зброї
як можна уявити собі братів по зброї без
хліба
а не треба уявляти бо тепер це
називається ветеранська спілка братів по
зброї імені
[музика]
і тому це наша справа буде книга
бути фільм
Даринка буде Брати по зброї
будуть ветерани
і все в них розсиплеться як прах
А ми переможемо
ми напевно Якщо говорити про
контекст спогадів то скоріш за все або
першим
стартом або
фінальним підсумком Це точно будуть
слова дарки її спогади і
Всім привіт Я чесно довго думала що
говорити тому що ніякими словами не
описати наскільки батько був крутим
Наскільки в нього була велика серця бо я
не знаю як можна було настільки сильно
любити свою справу Україну своїх
близьких свою сім'ю і
описувати нема сенсу ви всі його знали Я
рада що вас так багато сьогодні тут
зібралась Я впевнена що йому дуже
сподобався цей двіж бо якщо я так згадую
все моє життя Я в цьому росла знаєте в
самому дитинство це були його вірші його
пісні Я коли ми з Ірою
переглядали переклади його віршів Я кажу
я знаю це це пісня Я кожен майже в цих
віршів може проспівати тому що він писав
музику багато з цього було не записано
нас постійно співали вдома постійно
збиралися якихось таких також
неформальних ліжок де можна було
поспівати Він завжди був душею компанії
завжди збирав навколо себе музикантів
постійно я з ним десь за сценою
тусувались і це було дуже класно І потім
я звикла до цього Ого творчого життя
потім я звикла чекати його після того як
він пішов воювати я знала що все буде
добре його чекають не психую не реву я
не регута бачиш я наліво
і я знаю що все буде добре тому що
Він дуже сильно прикладався на мене і
він як батько Він завжди був моїм кращим
другом Я знаю що для кожного він там бо
він поет
Ветеран але для мене він Звісно що в
першу чергу був батьком І він був такою
людиною яка
він реально був для мене кращим другом
ми завжди працювали разом над усіма його
творчими проектами він скидав мені всі
Демки до своїх пісень вона знову робили
кліпи звичайно ж сварилась хлопали
тварин
у мене приблизно такий самий але саме
завдяки цьому ми робили щось круте
він був Так завжди дуже чуттєвий він
писав вірші Мені він писав вірші моїй
мамі і обожнював котиків якось знаєте І
саме класне те що вони якщо Все було
чудово почуття гумору тому я впевнена що
зараз ніхто не має плакати Бо він би
щось зараз замочив він в описі сміялися
Так що просто неможливо і навіть У
стресових ситуаціях Він завжди казав що
гумор завжди рятує і я не хочу дуже
багато розповідати про те що ми і так
знаєте але я б хотіла зачитати пару
віршів його вірші читати не можу в мене
не вистачає силу Я починаю ревіти і це
таке але знаєте Щось має не змінюватись
і Ось як я виконуючий обов'язки які
роблять його роботи я як виконуючий
обов'язки по поезіям рік пройшов папіч
продовжує писати тому все нормально все
буде нормально
тому
я дві штучки зачитаю
я батьківському бушлаті тут на сніг
лягала спати Я спала шкала квіти я була
єдина в світі хто не чув у небі бомби
хто не бачив білий світ що без нас
кудись летів чи там небо чи то в прірву
Чуєш світи постривай ми хотіли тільки
Миру ми на землі хотіли Рай Ми отримали
на пекло Ми отримали людське буде
світлий бій запеклий Бода радість буде
смерть я в батьківському бушлаті тут на
сніг лягала спати Ми не били мої браття
мене пів мій рідний син я чекала тут
весни розквітала як могла А коли я
прокидалась я співала і вела цих людей
кудись до раю цих людей кудись туди де
вони колись жили бо ці землі Україна бо
ці землі - Це є Я там в батьківському
бушлаті моя гріється Земля
[оплески]
другий вірш називається драконом ми
знаємо що Це є символ був важливий для
нього чув ми його звали драконом тому
співали драконові діти співали і кричали
вогнем слова їх розносили вщент ворогів
а здавалось тут просто слова не мовчали
драконові діти з ними пісня була лісова
і вони не чіпали ліси бо дракони жили з
тих часів коли лісом не була і міста але
Бог дарував їм намисто і з майбутніх
чарівних світів і дракони дивилися як
гарно і співали драконові діти бо не
марне життя їх дракона бо не марно він
світ захищав із намистим оправ він єдину
полюбив він її Україну мій старий і
чарівний дракон і співають драконові
діти підіймайся на цей Террикон і
побачиш як знову злітають підіймаються в
небо Дракони це не діти вже зовсім не
діти і вони розглядались по світу
і співали про тебе Дракони про твою
камуфляжну водою
Ну і напевно зараз цілком справедливо
щоб ця
згадали трьох лінтян патріот пізли і
пізли на завдання тоже патріот Олександр
погребицький
[оплески]
Дякую тобі
знаєте за останнім часом ми дуже-дуже
рідко збираємося такої компанії
єю і просто хотів би подякувати глібом
що ти нас зібрав
ми всі побачились не на волонтерських
справах а для спілкування для того щоб
згадати тебе друже
кліп
це та людина Я сьогодні вже казав там і
журналісти питали яка для мене є таким
кристалом справедливості
балансу
об'єктивності
і
ось коли ми створювали двох з ним
братів по зброї
Я навіть ні на секунду на сумнівався хто
має прописувати ідею принципи і всі ті
інші речі які має вести на собі будь-яка
організація
і Гліб
прописав їх так
що вони будуть служити для братів по
зброї я не знаю на сторіччя бо тільки
він так міг за це зробити
і
ми створили і Гліб вдихнув цю
організацію
ветеранську організацію яка з перших
днів
сказала що вона в політиці на відміну
від всіх інших які вже існували
в українському суспільстві
ми не побоялись це зробити
саме Гліб сказав що ми маємо бути
першими хто бере на себе
відповідальність бо дуже багато
ветеранів створюють організації
декларують що вони без політики А ти ж
помнишком там спілкуються вирішують свої
питання І от Враховуючи те що Гліб є
людиною яка
є об'єктивно кристально справедливо ми
зробили ми вирішили її зробити почесному
да як в армії кажуть
наскриваючись і не прячуся
зробити тією організацією яка
мала інтегрувати ветеранів політику які
успішно інтегрувалися Я хочу за це
подякувати вам Петро олексійовичу і всій
команді європейські солідарності
І абсолютно 100% ветеранів які стали
депутатами різних рівнів на місцевих
виборах на даний момент захищали
Батьківщину от такою таку справедливу і
використання чистої організації
[оплески]
а тепер я хочу щоб ви послухали яку
клятву хліб
склав для цієї організації яку приймали
всі члени будуть клятви вставай головні
убори зняти
[музика]
я учасник війни з Росією захисник
суверенітету та територіальної
цілісності України
Вступаючи до лав громадську організацію
Брати по зброї урочисто клянусь клянусь
дотримуватись принципів бойового
братерства поважати і підтримувати своїх
побратимів ніколи не залишати їхню Ані
на полі бою Ані в Мирному житті
зможу поставити
стандарт для інтересів України
[музика]
клянуся через все життя пронести
вірність Україні своєму народові
і садимом як стійкий воїн і
відповідальний громадянин
клянусь назавжди у будь-який спосіб за
будь-яких обставин і самовіддано
щастя від владою
буде готові з державою
[музика]
народу
добро чистої
тепер Як вам всім відомо людина
побратим друг батько
наш соратник який
склав ці слова присяги
його ім'я називається тепер Ця
організація А це значить що вона тепер
має подвійну відповідальність
перед суспільством і перед своїми
побратимами загиблими і вона має ще
співдостоїнством вже після війни
продовжувати справу яку Гліб
започаткував і нести ті принципи які він
в цю організацію вклав
На жаль сьогодні
не всі
члени не Всі голови обласних організацій
можуть бути присутніми з об'єктивних
причин
бо більшість з них знаходиться на фронті
але багато хто
захотів передати і поділитись з вами
словами
що він відчуває
і відчував на протязі року того року
коли хліба з нами не стало включить будь
ласка відеозвернення
своєї землі кожного дня Ми пам'ятаємо
тебе згадуємо твої настанови
нам тебе дуже не вистачає всій війні але
ми почнемось для того Єгипет кожному
російському окупанту Слава Україні
Героям слава
є керівником Дніпровської
Дніпропетровської обласної організації
братів далі
Привіт друже зараз Україна
як тебе не вистачає
твого досвіду не вистачає твого
життєвого військового досвіду поїхав
навіть і ніби не вистачає того
постійного борща
ми були сюди спілкувалися
Ти спитав в мою думку стосовно твоєї
пісні Мольфар і я тебе сказав що
ягадки не мають що в цей час коли поки
що таке геніальний текст
твоїй голові ми тебе знаємо дуже-дуже
Давно ми були на рибалки ну
навіть рибу
пізніше Звичайно людина коли читаєш свої
вірші коли Чуєш твої пісні розумієш
Наскільки ти був геніальним гуманізм Ти
залишаєшся глян
ною людиною я для себе окремо для себе
вирішив що ти залишився з нами ти просто
поїхав на якийсь
та далекі питання
А він на тому острові дуже-дуже Багато
наших хлопців зараз туди приїхав мій
друг жінка красота написала Олівер та
находяться пчёла мій колишній боєць там
знаходишся ти вбираєш на
[музика]
гітарі хлопці займаються своїми справами
На жаль зв'язок з цими послугами ну
поганий який завжди Це звісно про любили
це питання але все ж таки ніби ти завжди
залишаєшся з нами з нами в наших пам'яті
наших телефонах є
в Ютубі завжди можна побачити тебе
послухати навіть себе по
спілкувати Дякую що Ти залишаєшся в
нашому житті присматри
[музика]
вать там де стояти Як ірусні так і
внутрішнім ворогам
нікуди але я більше не впевнений що ми
обов'язково твоєю допомогою обіцяєте
[музика]
привіт
Привіт назавжди
в строю вас зброю як і назавжди з нами
його пісні його вірші його Незламна
позиція та його посмішка найкращим
шануванням його пам'яті стане наша
перемога яку ми обов'язково здобули
Слава Україні Героям слава
Україні
День пам'яті Нашого друга
побратима гідного сина України Глеба
владича
якого нам дуже не вистачає
який був справжнім козаком людиною якого
Я дуже поважаю він для мене ці рейс
мужності
справжнього українського чоловіка воїна
поет
дуже розвинена була людина але на жаль
на жаль
загинув як
ми обов'язково з ним Побачимось але не
сьогодні
колись після нашої Перемоги
[музика]
ви знаєте сьогодні Тамара казала
що він
нікуди не пішов він десь поряд з нами
І абсолютно була права
тому що Наприклад в мене є
абсолютно реальна історія
Польова
яка трапилась зі мною десь через два дні
після
того як все відбулось не знаю Може хтось
читав цю історію і публікував офіційно
але розкажу вам зараз її всім присутнім
на підтвердження слів Тамари
Це був бойовий виїзд ми виконували
штурмові дії на півдні штурмували
позиції противника випивали ворога з
закріплених його позицій
наш підрозділ
під'їхав точку десантування звичайно
десантування з машини
і
з цього самого моменту
Ти розумієш що ти потрапив в хаос просто
на реальний хаос який
в суміші запахами візуальними картинкою
хаосом
загиблими На жаль пораненими
розпитою технікою і так далі І так далі
Може хтось з вас дивився серіал Брати по
зброї
про висадку в Нормандію це приблизно та
сама картина
і в цьому хаосі ми пішки як справжній
десантники рухались близько 4 км повній
виплаті на допомогу нашим побратимам
під постійним щільним мінометним
обстрілом
ночував я в водопропускній трубі під
дорогою такі знаєте великі азбесток
На жаль
деякі побратими по дорозі були поранені
хтось загинув
але зранку коли я
Розплющив очі виліз на край труби для
того щоб перекурити
Я підняв голову подивився там поле
Польова дорога буде пропускна труба до
асфальтної дороги я побачив білого коня
я думав що у зв'язку з стресом там
відсутністю снад дві доби такими
активними подіями просто в мене якісь
галюцинації я звернувся до хлопців які
зі мною поряд коли я кажу ви теж бачите
цього білого коня
[музика]
передавати дослівно не було але там
звучали трохи інші слова
підійшов навпроти нашої труби
повернувся подивився нашу сторону
десь секунди 3-4 і пішов далі я просто
був в шоці чесно вам скажу закінчення
три дні ходив там навколо позиції наших
там де багато мін там де багато розтяжок
там дистанційного мінування ворогом і
так далі він жодної за три дні він не
зачепив
після цього жодного пораненого не було
аж допоки кінь не пішов і тоді там мене
поранило інших Я зрозумів що Гліб з нами
і згадав його пісню Да чорний кінь з
білими крилами десь із неба п'є
[музика]
ми обов'язково зустрінемось але ми зараз
[оплески]
Ай тут хлопці розповідали чоловіки
розповідали наше як їм не вистачає Гліба
в їх
військових справах
нам не вистачає його поезії А критично
не вистачає ми перечитуємо
передивляємося його youtube-каналу
знов заглядаємо в книгу
дівчата мені пишуть Іра я
коли мені зовсім-зовсім погано я
тякнувся до книги бабіча відкривала на
будь-якій сторінці починають читати і
мене наче відпускає а наші трохи стає
легше наче Він читає моєму серці це така
дуже дівоча тема
і ми у видавництві
коли відчули оцю пустку творчу
культурну відсутність
[музика]
важливих віршованих текстів про війну ми
як завжди ми робимо почали думати щось
цим робити І поспілкувалися з
поспілкувалися з нашими читачами
вирішили зробити
окремий конкурс імені Гліба бабіча
цей конкурс
віршів про війну він мав бути не тільки
для військових а для всіх хто переживає
війну зараз для всіх українців і нам
почали писати присилати поезії не тільки
з різних кутів України але із-за кордону
Ми отримали ми не уявляєте Для нас це
був такий такий захвати трохи шок бо з
цим всім потрібно було працювати Ми
отримали майже дві з половиною тисяч
поезій уявляєте собі і коли ми почали
відбирати їх ми відчули у кожній з них
Це було неймові рно важко ми відчули в
кожній з них
глібом бо всі вони були щирі бо всі вони
були від серця а понадче він
проголошував чужими словами
свої думки свої почуття і я хочу щоб
зараз ми з вами подивилися
відео на якому четверо наших фіналістів
у нас їх 70 з двох тисяч ми змогли
відібрати тільки 75
четверо з наших півфіналістів читають
свої поезії всі вони військові
представляє
щоб ми зараз промотаємо
Айра надіслала нам свій вірш За що ми її
неймовірно вдячні так от всі вони
військові з різних
місць вони вписали і відправляли нам
свої вірші і ми вдячні хліби тобі за те
що ти дав нам можливість не тільки
познайомитись з новими поетами
крутезними абсолютно але відкритий
Україні будемо мати можливість відкрити
Україні нові імена і перед тим як ви
будете слухати Я хочу сказати що ми не
зупинилися на цьому І вирішили
продовжити цей ряд монах і зараз у нас
іде відбір поезій на
23-23-го року і можливо Саме тут сидить
наш майбутній переможець відправляйте
будь ласка свої поезії На видавництво
Білка мишана вливо і уважно обов'язково
їх Приймемо і переглянемо А тепер
Валерій пузік
присутній будинок культури читати вірші
на окулярі сцені
дивитись порожній зал на повалені стіни
тут було 300 місць для людей на
урочистість весілля зараз вже розподів
вікна п'ятірка від градом сталі
і грати що стримить засохлою квіткою
посеред сцени
ніби має право вибухнути будь-якої
хвилини я стою я не знаю про що Читати
далі окрім війни в мене зараз більше
нічого немає окрім втоми та бруду під
нігтями окрім болю в тілі окрім плям на
правому боці окрім військової форми
вибраної саме для цієї миті у мене
більше нічого немає Я тут і грати
У мене зараз
моя література проростає всього насіння
мої слова протяг між книжковими шафами
замінованих окупантами сільських
бібліотек мої цитати з книг під завалами
мої вірші розстріляні
рядки На мережних плитах Вони готуються
початком кінця світу вони підписуються
іменами полеглих в боях вони дивляться в
небо крізь дірку в Стелі звучать
змученими голосами в ефірі радіостанції
будинок культури стоїть посткою
не наповнюється голоса
в коридорах
ящики і боєприпаси на сходах сліди
кров'ю поламані турнікети червоний слід
наш штори від солдатської роки мої вірші
поламані стоять на милицях у шпиталях
мої вірші рухають пальцями протезі мої
вірші більше мовчать ніж говорять моє
вірші дають рани і люблять хапаються за
життя
шоу у світі війна на вашу улюблену
телеканалі Забуття колецкайте долоньки
Поки вони у вас є то почеснічками поки
вони у вас є знайомтеся з гостями у
студії вони повернулись вогню очі їхні
земля вони розказують усе про війну яка
вона чудова і романтична знайомтеся
Перше місце це Андрій з основним вогонь
до війни працював пекарем Ох не передати
якісь смачні синабони він готував які
дароматні тепер Він чекає на
протезування алгориту А ось і другий ліс
- це Сергій темрява він обовнює ти щось
сміх а також ховатися у снах А це колір
сновидіння і не наданий кавуна арабіці і
небо За кого можуть випустити метеорити
зорі кулі наче яблуко з ділявою трубою
його підрозділ отримав посаду під ізюмом
у травні позиції на крили касеткою І
фосфором лише сновидіння лишився зробити
хвилинку новини найсохливішому
тракторному світі на телеканалі забуття
завтра переможемо які ми молодці Андрію
розкажіть про себе я ніхто і дім мій
спустошення Сергію Як ви себе почуваєте
Все цьом Це просто сон як помітити
звідси де ті доповідь двері Олю один би
хотіли помандрувати я поїхав би минуле
відмовити хлопців під тим хто посадку
реклама наталюканалі Забуття замість
звичайних запахів парфумів Обирайте
джунсу з надками крові землі та вогню не
бачите сонце третій тиждень по вас
накриває та Орлан дракує букви працює
Танчики у печінках жорстких гроних для
вас пропонуємо фігурка спечене життя
приймати кожного ранку нам ще серце
збиваючи лати з мигдальним молоком
купуйте також мікстуру байду то звісно
да втомився Андрію Про що ви мрієте
Андрій мовчить наче прихожани на
Літургії Сергію що ви бачите перед собою
темряву темряву темряву Олю чи я вас
друзі мої друзі тумани маки птахи ліси
Можливо там мої хлопці бо зверху за
декілька хвилин на телеканалі Забуття
відбудеться державна лотерея він не поле
А завтра на найсохливішими тонкому світі
війна поговоримо про таке громада
попрощалася з бійцем Святого подружжя
розлучається екстрасенс знає коли ми
переможемо домашнє печиво Слава Україні
і вже в суботу о 19:00 нове розважальне
реальне пішов Контрнаступ бону коли вже
в моїх висунете пацани
найзухливіше таксова у світі війна леска
йде долоньки Поки вони у вас є то потік
ніж ками Поки вони у вас є
беріть битого скла темряви підтримували
рік прокльонів і сліз
сумнівів чи є Бог рік болю і втрат
біженців і мерців рік в полоні солдата
бійців
рік вогню і руїн рік на дні Корабель рік
пральних машин вкрадених у людей
рідко спрощених ноль рік везуть на щиті
рік плюгавий король в бункері на самоті
рік палає росняк рік тримаємо стрій рік
живемо в піснях
зруйнованих мрій
від готелів і віз рік кордонів І меж
день прильотів погано рік ворожих пожеж
рік донатів на Дрон камери теплики рік
останній патрон хто має матюки
від панічних Атак
рік запасів про всяких зустрічей
рік ще раз піде за три частинки до
бережуть рік вже як знає світ Бучу
Херсон Бахмут
рід як застиглий Крик
[музика]
спротив триває рік
болі живе ліки
усміхнені труби на вулицях містах і
срібна перехрестя
[музика]
повертає сторінки життя
і з відстороненням оглядом
пальцями смерть так боляче так що тобі
на часах перестав і уже несправляється
півроку через
лікарню разом
як богдан любові обернеться на море
вставляє в магазин але стане любовне А
ти не почуваєш себе і з тобою
поблизу раптом Господь на хвилину
основної історії 3G інтернет і я вас
прогнози вчителів благодать
[музика]
у народі
круто
прочитання цієї відьми душа на тих хто
був бачив і вижив і напевно ще це має
тривати бо таких рефлексів буде дуже
багато і це дуже шляхетний проект і
ВІЛ цвякувати що він є народжена друзі
напевно що тут є ті хто мають свої
спогади давайте у нас не так вже багато
глобально часу
Якщо ви хочете щось сказати то будь
ласка виходьте сюди можна зібратися
зараз попросимо щоб для
присутності там більше Глібов В цьому
залі була якась з його пісень а Ви
матимете дві хвилини дві-три хвилини
зібратися думками підходьте сюди
представляйтеся до того є Кажіть Ну і
відповідно Там ми зможемо також
обмінятися своїм емоціями поки ми
виберемо пісню Напевно що
Героям слава
мені мінус
називати твоє ім'я
тому що твоя справа
твоє життя
Дружба з грибом
триває зараз
міцно мови слів
два роки
все вийшло так коли тобі
приїхав
до цього Христа тут казали про сльози ну
сльози Це не про мене Повірте просто
коли я побачила
світлини новий шеврон
через хвилину має дружина сказала нам
все треба і доїхати додому тому що
сльоза
вона вирвалась коли я прочитала
те що закріпилося
пам'ять хлібом ветеранство
другий
не багато значить варто ці Словакії
створив іноді клятви я стояв таки позад
Андрія
Я теж давав
вийшло так
що з маленькою пралкою
царя
знаходиться в моїй родині
Якщо мати по зброї будуть створювати
музеї і скажуть повернути моя родина
гордістю повернеться пляцок
друга Я вибачте трошки не в дві хвилини
я
коли познайомилися з Римом ну первоз
зустріч друга перва була Господи потім
друга
Хотів він звернув
поряд вона мої руки він побачив телефон
і каже він каже з такою вона ящірки
прокатався
Луганщину Донеччини
і потім на цей більшого зустрічі Ми
зустрічаємося зустрічаємо мене глібом з
маркером і їм каже так ну про плани Що
далі адвокати там оце все кажете
Почекай тут одною дуже-дуже доброї
людини
тобі подарунок
та дуже-дуже добра людина
там
не так давно 53 бригади
Гром батальйоні
я кажу Та ні тут на ньому одна нитка
Останеться
Він дуже для мене дорога
отак і ще
одну хвилину
ситуація така телефонують згоду вогневої
підтримки 93-ї бригади
в минулому це було 20 окремі
мотопіхотним
розвідником 5 років
і каже Анатолійович виручає
повна що таке
було два дрони
звернувся до гриба він
вечером коли його воно все
сказав що
одруження вирішуємо повір мені і
закрутилось Це колесо закрутилось
і все
доходило до фінальної фази
я набираю
так тихо як зараз
потім
створити я такого щеплення
ковтають
[музика]
10-20 десь Я не знаю
просто за один вечір і на все життя
без нічого
в своїх поряд людина каже Я знаю
всі гроші зліпимо
14 жовтня
2022 року я з підтримав олексійовичем
на пам'ять про нашого Гліба
виконав те що ми
це запланували тільки там не один малий
був там були Там було 50
там було генератори Я пам'ятаю а було
все те
що отримала
бригада і користувалась бригада а не
один батальйон і не одна рота І не один
з одним
потім
одна друга третя поїздка я приїжджаю і
мені
хлопці дають
хлопці дають мені
мені оце подякував
А я коли зразу прочитав там
як скромність людина скромна не вчить
кажу що це на рамочку не знайшли
[музика]
нам надо щоб ти отдала так
щоб оті руки які це приймають
почули наші руки і через наші Ті руки
узнали ту подякує шану яку ви зробили
так що риба я включаю цю подяку
Петра Олексійовича Порошенка ну це твоя
[оплески]
А якщо тут є
пісня навіщо Гліба Я не знаю як
підключитися тому
пішов імпровіз імені глібаба більше Він
казав що не буде
зараз
після нового я прочитаю вірша Ти
потримайте сир добре
[музика]
Мене звати В'ячеслав Купрієнко
загибом я познайомився в Дніпрі на
фестивалі після народження АТО
і я до цього знав
це ім'я слідкував за його поезією
коли вони були такі російською мовою у
нього я сам родом перш з тих країв і
російську мову вже здійснили
серцем душу не лягали але коли я побачив
[музика]
вірш Гліба
один із його улюблених
мою рідну професію Бог любить розвитку
я зробив пісню і от тут дуже згадували
про те які Гліб такі був
вимоговий до всіх і коли я йому показав
пісню цю
Ну бачите він трошки
на нашій країні
і вони повірите я зробив п'ять варіантів
музичних
і це було не те як це було ну я сам
відчував що воно важко народжується але
на сам кінець я повернувся до першого
варіанту вже
Гліб як кажуть святив це пісню Я дорогу
запи
с єдине що з його дозволу поміняв перше
слово
називалась в нього
нищити ворог Це не гріх давай так по
військовому
велику ворогам
і
[музика]
Це не гріх
по
[музика]
при і кажуть
що ми
по-іншому правило не
про непони не звідки
квитки
[музика]
слова чи як махнуть
з Америки немає прав
тому що я
Бог люблю
[музика]
матуся
ми щоб не трапилось все мене
[музика]
тому що
без пройти по краю не головне
буває важко прийти назад
ти наза
д собачі янгова відкривав
смерті немає прав
тому що я
[музика]
собачий янгол махнуть крилом
смерті немає прав
тому що я
не було Бог любить Кожного року я був
[музика]
дякую вам друзі
той
сценічний той
Я не знаю як ти це робиш Це так страшно
це ужас Всім привіт Я Олена подруга
Гліба хочу прочитати вірш який
присвячений був йому
живий бо завтра може вже не настати
лічильник став отак закінчилась днів
Я просто хотіла спитати Як тобі там у
раю брати правда ж на всі смішні
тобі згори Донеччини канонада правда ж
звучить як трохи нерівний драм слова
промов сама підліткова бровада і як
іграшкові кульки пакети грана як там раю
брати ти там
в раю для пам'яті ви воїнів завжди
звучать фанфари і віскі рікою і натовпи
гарних жінок і більше не треба тримати
важкі удари і більше не треба чути
потворні чвари і завжди набитий рибою
райвий той Струмок і сонце заходить із
сходить тоді коли ти захочеш а ночі
виключно Зоряні і то завжди Зорепад і ти
сидиш і з гітарою і безкінечно не хочеш
і пишеш пісні а в них оспівуєш Зоряні
теплі ночі і правда ж братику більше не
хочеш на землю назад
і все ідеально в раю для поетів і воїв і
я не реву а дивлюся у небо блакить туди
де Для тебе завжди буде повно набоїв бо
Рай той дається дуже важкою ціною бо
голос тих хто сумує там тихо дуже
звучить
люблю тебе
моя кохана поки звучить можете зібратися
думками часу у нас не так вже багато тут
має бути саундтрек музикантів які грають
в цьому закладі цього вечора тому
думайте
друзі Я буду вже завершувати стрім я
дякую вам всім що ви були разом з нами я
вам ще раз покажу цей чудовий зал Я
сподіваюся що ви змогли теж відчути те ж
саме що і ми обіймаю вас всіх
глібич це все заради тебе привіт